how is coded nineteen different from the
flu in terms of you know how it you know
in a rash to the body and just how it
spreads well it's similar in some
respects step in that it's a respiratory
illness that's transmitted by the
respiratory route it gives a degree of
pathology that's mostly pneumonia the
reason it's different is that it's very
very much more transmissible than flu
and more importantly it's significantly
more serious let me give you some very
quick numbers okay bro mortality of
seasonal flu that you and I confront
every year is about 0.1 percent the
overall mortality of coronavirus is
about one percent sometimes like in
China it was up to two to three percent
which means it's at least ten times more
serious than the typical influenza so
when people kind of compare it in some
respects in as some similarities but
it's really really different in its
degree of seriousness and is that I know
they've been hearing a lot of kind of
rumors around our numbers around from
you when I showed up in China to other
different countries you know the
disparity or discrepancy amongst ages
and how it affects obviously underlining
underlying health conditions or you know
if you're a little older that it affects
you a little bit more seriously worse as
that's shown differently here in the
states in terms of you know different
age brackets and and just the severity
of the cases of death versus in air
units and and all those type of things
yeah mostly the same but with some
interesting may be disturbing
differences if you look at China you
look at Europe you look at South Korea
it predominantly is reasonably benign if
you want to call it that you get sick
but you don't get into serious trouble
if you're young very heavily weighted
towards the elderly and those
the underlying conditions heart disease
lung disease diabetes kidney disease
those are the people who have a higher
degree of mortality we know that for
sure we're seeing that a lot of now in
the United States but what we are
starting to see is that there are some
people who are younger people your age
young healthy vigorous who don't have
any underlying conditions who are
getting seriously ill it's still a very
very small minority but it doesn't mean
that young people like yourself should
say I'm completely exempt from any risk
of getting seriously ill and that's the
reason why we talk about being careful
of physical distancing doing the kind of
social separation it means not only for
the elderly but the young people have to
do with two for two reasons one you need
to protect yourself because you're not
completely exempt from serious illness
but do you can become the vector or the
carrier of infection well you get
infected you feel well and then you
inadvertently and innocently pass it on
to your grandfather your grandmother or
uncle who's on chemotherapy for cancer
that's what we got to be careful of what
about immunity if you get kovat this is
also something that you guys want to
listen to the podcast I'm gonna get it
out for you hopefully within the next 48
72 hours but what do you think about
that is is that is it likely the OBD
mune this is a very interesting question
because what we now understand about
this virus and how aggressive it is is
it has the ability to hijack what is
called interleukin-1 beta a very
important part of our immune system we
know that people who start off with low
levels of this interleukin-1 beta have a
worse outcome British researchers are
now looking at giving interleukin-1 beta
to help bump up the immune system
intranasally for people but when you get
the virus and some people it lowers your
il-1 B and makes you even more at risk
for a bad outcome so you know all of the
things that affect your immune system
are things that we should think about
and most importantly understand
that the immune system is regulated by
your gut bacteria and that takes us
right back to talking about food all
right speaking of that we've got another
question here what are the specific
foods or supplements you would look at
right now to shore up your immune system
the most important supplement I think
that you can take for your music and
would be sleep and I think so very
underrated but yes not getting it I
think not getting enough sleep is
devastating to your immune system so it
means turning the TV off in the
afternoon and evening not watching the
TV during dinner and do everything you
can to get a good seven hours of sleep
or maybe even eight hours in terms of
taking supplements I think there's good
data that in terms of your immune
function vitamin E and zinc are good
choices and as you and I talked about on
our podcast earlier today this Phi set
and FIS atin is I think something we
should think about in terms of allowing
our aging immune system to become more
youthful and more functional we've got
to work on defense we don't have
anything on offense really that's
available to us so we got to work on
defense that means immunity and we
talked about immunity we're talking
about our gut bacteria and our most
important line advanced it regulates our
immune response and regulates
inflammation so eat the good prebiotic
fiber foods like garlic onions leeks
broccoli a Jerusalem artichoke if you
can get it
I'll take a prebiotic fiber that you can
get online or at the health food store
this is the time to be thinking about
your medications that might be damaging
your gut bacteria like acid blocking
drug that a lot of people take and may
not necessarily need one of the
questions I think I just saw was where
do you get by setting and you were
spelling it wrong person you ask the
president it's F is as in Sam eat ein
generally made from extracted from
strawberries but really got a lot of
cool data about it in terms of
rejuvenating immune function what does
it mean to be recovered and can you get
the virus
second time and if yes or no does that
influence you know how testing kind of
goes in the futures trying to detect an
antibody or even a dress like that
conversation around murder mmunity and
how to really not let this be a cyclical
thing that uh or is it or is it a
cyclical thing in terms of you know
what's expected in the future okay step
yet three four five can you get the
virus a second time let's get to the
first one which was also important all
right if you're infected and you recover
the question is why can you go out and
be safe to not infect others the general
rule is you have to have two cultures 24
hours apart that are negative that's our
focus now as more people get infected
that likely is not going to be feasible
so we're gonna have to set some
guidelines up days following the
diminution of symptoms we're not there
yet cuz we don't know as much about how
far out you could be shedding virus
first thing second thing your main
question once you get infected can you
get reinfected we haven't done the
specific testing to determine that but
if this acts like every virus similar to
it that we know the chances are
overwhelming that if you get infected
recover from infection that you are not
gonna get infected with the same virus
which means you can then safely go out
into the community and feel immune so
that you could not only protect yourself
get back to work
get back to your job but you'll be able
to have what you refer to as herd
immunity enough people who recovered in
the community that gives the virus very
little chance to spread rapidly
that's what's referred to as herd
immunity everybody until this is over
she should practice some degree of
physical distant singing care not big
crowds wash your hands a lot be careful
you can do that and still get back to
somewhat of a normal life
there's a big difference between the
extreme of locking a city down right
opening it up a bit but being more
careful than you normally would be and I
think there are places in the country
now where you want to look at carefully
and said you know maybe you want to pull
back a little bit on the restriction so
long as you just don't let it rip and
say I don't care what happens sorry
you treat New York City a little bit
different the way you treat Nebraska
some of the data right now indicates
that there are a lot more younger people
in America being hospitalized with
coronavirus between the ages of 20 to 58
and you know people say gee why would
that because you know these people 20 30
years old they are healthy but I'm sorry
to report the reality is that the youth
of America are not necessarily healthy
we rank in America at least 46 in terms
of health care on the global scale was
very high rates of obesity and so we're
not really super healthy as it relates
to so many chronic into degenerative
conditions high rates of obesity high
rates of diabetes which we know are
associated with worse outcome as it
relates to coronavirus so this is a real
call to younger people to take the
preliminary information about distancing
themselves very seriously that's your
best defense in a situation where we
don't have an offense another question
let me just ask this what's the
correlation with kovat and sense of
smell yeah interestingly there's been
some reports of loss of sense of smell
as being the harbinger for this having
further symptoms not exactly sure why
but it may be that you know the the
cilia are rather the the nerve endings
in your nose that are involved in
transmitting sent to the brain might be
colonized with the virus and then lose
their function Sanjay Gupta I think was
one of the earliest to call that out and
some think about what's the biggest
piece so just misinformation and that
you know that's kind of been out and you
know for public consumption and what
would you kind of say do to correct that
whatever issue that is you know I think
you brought it up in one of the
questions that you asked me this the
economy between people who are being
frightened to death of it versus people
who don't even believe it and think it's
something trivial that you don't have to
worry about I'd like to get the people
in the country to realize that we are
dealing with a serious problem it's
something that we've modified our lives
it's not convenient to lock yourself in
it's not convenient to not do the kinds
of things it's not convenient for you
not to be playing basketball but we're
going through a period of time now where
we gotta as a country pull together
don't get frightened don't get
intimidated use the energy to be able to
confront it and do the kinds of things
that will put an end to it so I want to
get rid of that misconception that is
extremes either the world is gonna end
or we don't want to do anything it isn't
that it's somewhere in the middle if you
want more advice wisdom guidance from
other successful entrepreneurs on how
you can navigate the coronavirus
situation check out the video right
there next to me I hope you find it
valuable and continue to believe and
I'll see you there
disappointment is a very complicated
emotion